welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
in another we work Lots none who works
up evening I mean another we work I'm
joined by Tim Lowry who is the founder
of a recruitment agency called
projectors consulting and you guys
specialize in the med tech industry
don't you that's exactly right
HM yeah thank you very much for inviting
me on no worries so um I've actually
been looking forward to this obviously
having so getting to know your business
a bit more I'm really excited to hear
about the journey up until now as as I
was saying beforehand where I always
like to star on this podcast and this
show is or how how did Tim enter the
recruitment industry let's talk about
that yeah like a lot of people at the
time I sort of fell into it but at the
same time there was some sort of method
to the madness so essentially my wife
got a job or was working in Lund at the
time and we were living in Northampton
further up north and I start to look for
jobs in in London and registered with a
couple of recruiters yeah and then it's
a classic so PR say whatever you want to
call it a classic flip and there were
sales recruiters and met with CD CD
sales recruitment the time and yeah got
to know those guys seem like a great
environment good people hmm
and yeah when from their release what
was you doing before sells
yeah door-to-door sales for a while
which was always a good grounding a good
grounding of the charity sales as well
so charity fundraiser yeah so a lot on
the street yeah well that's the thing is
you Tim is actually really quite tall so
you're not gonna be suppose you really
tall that fine and so to prop us out you
must be in the perfect Rhett Rhett and
so join CD and then just sort of let's
talk a bit about that for a second and
how long were you there for was it like
four or five years or so yeah almost the
day I think now I mean that's a real
solid stint for your verse
recruitment yeah I mean it's a good
environment got the opportunity to
progress within the business
yeah good opportunity to UM to earn as
well was just the classic route of join
as a sort of training your consultant
exactly become a manager yeah yeah the
classic sort of wrote started as there's
like different models do they do in
terms of BD okay teams and delivery and
also manager kind of this or 180 model
120 almost really yeah okay I think that
that works out in terms of sensors yeah
degrees whatever so you'd have a BD that
get the job on a consultant that would
find candidates and then imagine that
manage the process oh really yes okay so
just a sort of framework then so we're
definitely pretty much six years on the
dot
Joan is a consultant did you go into
what the BD team or the BB team I'm
starting construction sales recruitment
okay so which had great success there
and weren't worked and got mentored by a
great boss very sort of tough love very
direct feedback a live in in in the in
the bear pit so to speak okay which was
an amazing grounding so obviously tough
at the time getting such direct feedback
you know yeah right there but actually
it's unbelievable a chat with Colin
Chandler and then I moved into the IT
side the business okay in the BDM role
yeah and then med medical med take place
really and then and then what did you
what you grew that from scratch no I
took over the team so there's a chap
that was running it that moved into
another company as it happened okay the
opportunities step ups and even and then
how long was you in that role about
years yeah and then in that role you was
what you had a team that you yeah yeah
so BDM couple of consultants as well so
we're doing doing really well but I
think at the time I had that kind of
bugs to try and do something myself yeah
that makes sense that's all there's
great opportunity within within medtech
and to grow some specialists on a global
scale yeah I look around the market it
was there's no really doing actually and
our Marcus you know it's incredible it's
growing all the time it's actually said
to really explode over the next decade
as well yeah kind of thing let's just
talk a bit about before you got before
you obviously had that realize you're
talking about there so you the full
process of you want to start your own
agency so what I mean what what what
sounds great about that is it seemed
like it was always in this little real
heavy beady cells focus role which
typically if I think of the
the messages that I get a lot is like
that's the most challenging part for a
lot of people with the BD there so
that's of a piece but I guess to sort of
round off that experience she managed it
a bit there with the mentor that you had
what early on what were some of the
challenges for you let's just start
there for a second what challenges early
on when you as a consultant okay so we
are nearly days in the criminals yeah
yeah I think it's yeah it's definitely
better than farm recruitment the first
of the first few months you know it's
tough it's a much more direct sales
environment and b2c yes if that makes
sense yeah obviously that the control if
you know if you're inexperienced that
the control you have over certain
scenarios and situations isn't as good
if that makes sense in terms of making
sure you know you can do at some point
you know interview is more happy in the
world perhaps except to the clients
committed and then obviously balancing
everything as well like that that kind
of um you know balance see all those
spinning plates of the essence so trying
to control everything and I think the
way that I did it and I'd also suggest
other people to do it as well as just
work for it to learn be a bit of a
sponge of how how William was you to
take that tough love feedback then from
the time sometimes you know okay
you know but I think like a lot of
things if you get feedback reflect on it
you can improve and the improve yeah and
it's great and then you can you can you
can be a better version if you self
context day and keep on going
onwards and upwards so is really good
for me to see really what would your
gorilla yeah I did well so better yet or
presidents clubs and that sort of thing
so because of the the way they did the
the model I built 560 but it was like
this one sweaty model if they're a
best-of month was 98 97 one really yeah
that's how it was over a hundred work is
obviously so your role was to get the
job he's right the clamp here that was
actually I was consultant filling the
roles and then when our client piece is
a new start up to in basically did yeah
how much looking back how useful were
helpful was it that you you were in that
environment is really able to focus
because that is definitely if I think
when I started
people out there as you ascend juggling
and spin in a different place and stuff
like how helpful was it like just being
like just really focusing on your
chronic culture was was very focused was
it yeah there wasn't too much you
haven't had fun and what-have-you but it
was it was a focus culture that sort of
led from from from the the leaders then
the directors people are Brad and of
Sakhalin I mentioned as well so the
culture was you know work hard culture
philosophy head down and what have you
so so I think that pretty helps actually
yeah but generally speaking anyway I was
kind of focused on fun to build soon off
and build a career really I'm pretty
serious about trying to be good if
they're Mason's wasn't just there to
it's around I wanted to be good to ran
that off then what what so for those
that are listening that maybe early on
year in 18 months in or even earlier
what was what's the sort of advice from
the journey you've been on now which is
yeah again I own your own agents in it's
been a while since you did back in in
those days 100 K a lot what what's your
sort of what should sort of go-to advice
for your whole learning experience and
hiring people now that people can sort
benefit from what you're typically yeah
also yeah just from I respect what say
to people it's it's about getting ahead
unlearning not letting you ego getting
away that make sense yeah and realizing
it's a long game as well yeah not gonna
be you know an absolute legend overnight
don't be brilliant at what you did
overnight learn develop try and be
better every day at what you do mmm look
at look at the great people in that
business you're working with how can
learn from them as well ask questions
look for feedback look for criticism mmm
really you naturally do that early on
yeah I was actually I was definitely a
sponge looking for feedback definitely I
think it does separate people is really
like a sports book the other day in
there saying is it like a football
manager yeah and shelah to say but he
was saying the place that used to come
to him that wanted criticism which yes
that had a really bad career the ones
who didn't care they didn't want people
they couldn't handle feedback those guys
are like look what could I do better in
the last game even though the mason
games got a hat-trick whatever they
liked criticized okay yeah I know I've
been completely run I think in today's
world as well the younger people coming
through Hamm how many people in today's
world do you like taking criticism a bit
more difficult like people don't even
like getting to like from their post you
know I mean you know I guess the age
that we've moved into it obviously this
was like 12 years ago yes exists it's
come up a lot so look if you're if
you're listening right now who who
around you is are the people that you
wanna be learning from I'm asking them
questions are you actively trying to
seek feedback I think that's great
advice
so have you always wanted to have your
own business then like what did the sort
of recruitment help sort of fuel that
entrepreneurial spirit
probably helps her feel really out I
think I was kind of search hearing a
guess like a lot of people mmm one order
didn't really know ya throughout the
majority of my younger younger kind of
days and life and what have you and then
you know it's great industry part of you
know if you if you start to excel at it
be you know be good as a recruiter it's
a great platform to then go on and do
all sorts of things you know other
people have gone into different markets
and obviously stayed within companies
and grown with it yeah it gives you an
amazing grounding I think in terms of
sales in terms of organization all sorts
of different skills you need people
skills but yeah something that I've
thought about for a while and then the
opportunity kind of arose in terms of my
personal life as well
my wife was pregnant with our first my
son basically yes I was like if I don't
do it now when you're gonna do it yeah
it's always interesting that my old boss
are used to work for he started the
recruitment business when and his wife
was pregnant and it's like if you were
to look for teacher CLE well how do you
start a business when you know I mean
it's actually happened like I've
sponsored a lot of people I remember the
recruitment days where it's a lot of
people and actually started a business
around up here because I think is that's
automated miss like wow okay shits about
to get serious like
there's a new way more responsibility
when if I'm really been thinking about
it yeah when when is Emily a bit of time
so what did you see in them so that
definitely impacted your decision-making
what did you see in the med tech piece
that that really sort of for you know
what this is at what was anything there
that in hindsight I think there's
there's a few things actually so first
of all the markets are great with to be
part of in terms of the actual companies
we're working with the products they're
making okay making a real difference to
people's sure if you see some of the
videos out there on YouTube even of
medical products and what have you what
they're doing so that's awesome to be
part of a part of that industry so
enjoyed enjoyed it from that perspective
the growth in the market as well it's
huge and it's always going to be
changing innovating how did you
determine that out of interest how did
yeah how did you sort the term strategic
ly look I think it's just realizing that
ultimately we've got the world
population is growing right yeah I'm not
down to medical technologies no
technologies as much as anything yeah
everyone's living longer so that creates
a great opportunity we all kind of want
to live forever or yeah definitely
definitely
the best life we can live the healthiest
life we want that for our friends for
our family so holistically people can
invest in yeah smart and it's you know
it's a safe market as well in terms of
you know global economies and might be
again because of those reasons hmm you
know if we've got a last couple of quid
to spend you know and it can help us if
we're not very well reporting to spend
on that self as well okay cool so and
when did you start the when did you stop
project to source always what September
2012 okay so let's think about this sort
of first year for a second cost your
batters so your your wife that was your
pregnant first child how many kids have
you got now so first child and then so
did you have a plan at this stage like
was the what was the strategy to you for
you to start this business yeah it's a
good point I think when the early days
probably not enough of a plan I'd say
okay so just kind of recruiting trying
to get some money and then yeah
go from there okay I thought my time
again I probably just worked out a bit
more but I think at the time I'm it's
more the the challenge of seeing if I
could grow so yes it's just my first
year pretty much the whole first year
certainly for the first about six months
firstly taking seven months and my that
was myself so working from home for the
first three or four months and my son
was born then obviously more difficult
to work from home yeah the first office
often if it's no one then I know we
spoke about this but there's a brilliant
picture of you in there like you at your
like kitchen table I think the database
is in the background let's think about
that for a second because I think I
think that definitely is probably
someone listen right now thinking about
stand there and recruitment business or
even listening ear on the early days
that that can be real tough right so
firstly where did where the projects has
come from what was where that name come
from how do you think about yes so the
idea was always wanted to work with
startup businesses start businesses grow
yeah the ideas if you work with us you
we project you upwards if that make
sense okay together us we can protect
you for your business up so that's the
idea in the logo as well as like two
people moving up with careers their
lives so it's about growth really okay
so first six months predominate working
at home pretty much yeah pretty much at
home and on my own which is weird as
well really
that's elite was there was it was the
mindset just need to get cash in the
bank yeah just wanted to work very hard
to got up early started to started
working like 7:00 off seven cents go up
really well and what what was the
approach was you just predominate
focusing on getting jobs on yeah get new
jobs on new clients it's off so you know
restrictions as you do get any
candidates and lead so really going kind
of old school and go really just flowers
on the phone as much relationship
exactly yeah on the phone as much as
possible speaking to Canada's clients
except trying to build up build up the
market and myself essentially so but
yeah that the kind of the weirdness of
being on your own in the room doing it
is
yeah it's very different what I hoped
you get through that then an early
period I guess I had to is it's that
kind of sense of I think one of the
biggest motivates a lot of people have
especially entrepreneurs is the fear of
failure so it's kind of have to do no
you're right I think literally having no
plan B obviously scary but at the same
time it's like there is no there's no
option there's not a virgin so how did
you do in those first six months like
revenue wise to remember loads oh so you
didn't do like a deal for a couple of
months how long's it been so started
training September 2 the first deals in
sort of December I think yeah three
months about three months and then did
quite a few in December generate
sessions with and then build up from
there so yeah obviously remember the
first kind of deals and were happy when
the first when you actually opposed to
get paid for the first so what so what
was you doing what we're talking like 10
20 K month for like what a couple
hundred some in the first year and then
and then grew up from there and then
basically one thing I didn't mention
when I said the business I didn't want
to just be a sort of independent yeah
because you said you didn't have a plan
but you know yeah but you knew it wasn't
like it wasn't like the Tim Lowry
kitchen in a show like I knew I wanted
to build something out really but I
didn't like go into the intricacies of
our business berths so when did you so
after six months then and obviously
getting cash in what would so then you
start you didn't work from home then did
you like it did you make sense before we
work even existed so it was um it was
yeah like a shared office like another
company yeah it did help see people
working what have you and kind of
cracking on so it felt a bit more so
professional like I was making progress
yeah and what we do okay so I've ruled
then the first 12 months
definitely people gonna perceive those
as the hardness right so so first six
months was getting money in the bank
old school just wanna build relations
being proactive and then for the last
sort of six months of those first twelve
months then was that when you all she
went into a shared office yeah Aaron
yeah hiring people a business Soviet
first hires a couple of apprentices we
hired them to start off with that was
maybe Genesis yeah why did you go down
that route I'm honestly I was just
trying to see what the most
cost-effective way of doing things and
also more more so basically my wife was
on maternity leave at the time yeah and
she heard back was actually recruitment
and recruitment training yeah so we had
some resource there that meant that I
could and she came to the business
part-time mm-hmm I could focus on
billing and new business yeah and she
could help train up when did she get
involved in the graduates so I was
around that sort of time so we're
talking September October really lucky
Aaron okay people say and yeah so you
recognize her strengths and she
recognized her strengths obviously and
then so the full process was one just be
a bit smart in terms of cost effective
on if we could transfer people art yeah
how them our way of working how how did
that work is that quite easy to do now
I've done if you've done it recently our
apprentices lot worse yeah we hired
normally one or two princes every year
so really the most recent couple joined
us about six months ago so what for
people listening that could be a great
way to get some people in the business
what's the just talked a bit about that
for a second what's the sort of process
of getting apprentices some apprentice
agencies really almost like rector X and
what have you that they're really good
and people would you normally advertise
our the advertising on behalf of my
people that wanted an apprenticeship you
can and his apprenticeship I think it
connects do any recruitment now it's in
sales we didn't like admin support
happier we've got a couple of princes
from that as well so it's a good no no
it's nice to actually I'm quite
opportunities for young people as well
yeah yes sure not just folks on the
graduate market but the people that
perhaps actually it wasn't the right
choice for them to go to University of
tomatoes yeah they wanted to think yeah
I mean I mean if you're an apprentice
going into that top environment you
described and just you found you got
make [ __ ] happen I mean there's a lot
you can learn in that tough environment
yeah absolutely princess that Beamer
this about five six years and they're
really
also around that time had more
experienced persons with Rebecca Chuck
with Alexander early first few employees
I'd actually placed him as a candidate
iams think at least once really in
medical sales okay so yeah and I think I
obviously yeah did they put Koster done
ages ago okay what was it no doubt when
I was preparing for this so what was it
like working with the other half mate
what does that like it's good yeah it
certainly helps in terms of the
foundation the business you know and it
also the fact is sort of part-time as
well as a couple of days ago to help to
keep me sane as well a little bit and
that's because you know we could go for
like lunch together and stuff whereas if
you got you know babies and stuff home
screaming plus you got a lot pressure
the business yes nice to spend like an
hour just I'm assuming did it help
though that like she fully understand
what the hell was going on Jeannette
exactly sure she understood obviously
what we're trying to do as a business so
that side of it plus you've got the
background in supporting getting the
best out of people which you know it's a
great skill to have
yeah it's very hard to do so but I've
always seen the one advice I'd given to
take out from other people with their
businesses and feedback I've got from
other people in a similar situation yeah
probably the hardest when the hardest
things to do if you don't come to scale
a bit especially it's just you yeah it's
the balance between billing and growing
up a business yeah and then also
training developing other people yeah if
you try and do everything yourself is
you know hex fit so that's that was a
having so much value there that's
amazing I think sometimes you know
naturally with our egos and stuff we try
and do everything ourselves
yeah but they need I can imagine if
early on that well right early on yeah
so okay mate to run that off there in
the first year what was the would what
did you generate revenue wise in that
first year I remember I think it's maybe
a couple hundred about to enter
grandmother at the first year from from
scratch and then sort of doubled at the
next year and biggest so I guess for
people along their journey they sort of
ran the half what you know now knowing
what you know now anything that just to
sort of ran off that first year would
you have done anything differently or
what would sort of be there
people looking to take that leap
tomorrow there especially if it's a if
you are doing something on your own
yes it's reach out to other people yeah
yeah seek out people I've done it before
so I got like you know advisers and went
to speak to people that groaned
recruiting companies before successful
companies and and got advice and then
went to like round table type news
stand-ups and what have you so don't
feel like you're on your own even yeah
and I think those willing to help help
you out and and be be willing to say
that they're on board as well and I
think that's definitely I know you're
involved in different networks and stuff
but I think that's definitely even more
the case now isn't it and today people
are willing to help with it we're in a
super connected world now where maybe
back then you maybe had to do a bit more
work to find people but now like you
could reach out to those people
yeah there's all sorts of different
organizations that we're part the ideal
see there's some other ones
understanding the market but those guys
have been amazing for us so yeah there's
a lot of people out there that are happy
to give you some time but really did you
and then you mention briefly earlier bow
you didn't have much of a plan how much
should people plan that how much should
people have a business plan around there
yeah the reality with the business plan
is especially in a fluid con environment
or acrimony it's gonna change quite
often so yeah I'm writing it you know
once a quarter what have you yeah you
know we've got long-term vision right
now for the business and I did the start
of growing some business right great
value yeah in a company and have a
company that you know potentially could
sell in the future however big be aware
that things can change quite quickly
yeah let's be fluid hmm and also you
know the great thing about about a plan
as well is you can you can change it and
you know would you agree then it'd be
beneficial to have some sort of
direction or intent salutely I need to
have an intention of the key things as
well I think sometimes is people's
sometimes I'm sure doing to build a
really big business doing more of a
lifestyle business yeah weird or a bit
both and kind of get trapped in there
yeah it's good to understand from day
one what suits you exactly that sort of
intention in it it's gonna impact and
help the decision making yeah
okay and their careers in their life
because you're responsible not only for
yourself if you're hiring other people
it's also there yeah their futures as
well so it's important that you can give
them a clear plan okay so so that was
year one
so obviously projects us now it's been
in business what seven years it's in a
bit year so let's just think about sort
of the second year maybe to the fourth
year right let's just think about what
went over there so second fourth years
so going into the second year then how
big was your team at that point then so
second year would have been maybe four
people for that yeah yeah and then what
did that by sort of year for what we're
looking at there see if four were ups
about fifteen I did yeah fourteen
fifteen times as well was that so we've
moved office a couple times by then so
yeah so you'd year to two year four I
mean that's quite a bit of growth I
think what what I've been messaged a lot
about so how many people have you got in
the business now just for any six yes we
can talk about as a whole but I guess
you may have experiences when you speak
to people but I've got a lot of messages
around
hisham lot I'd love to hear from
business owners on sort of how they've
approached or they're experiencing
scaling a business from two people five
people to 15 20 and that that's a rule
that it seems like from the
conversations that I've had and sort of
the message is really challenging it is
challenging gets different stages and
you tend to kind of plateau so
importance needs to change certain
aspects where you run the business
meaning at the next level so what was
the plateau do you think it's your first
of all it's just you and then it's like
gets about five people and get a bit of
critical mass together so almost like
once you get to that level that's like a
recruitment team isn't it yeah you know
yeah in the recruitment companies normal
to four or five people get to that stage
as well then the next stage to get to
sort of like ten people you've got a
couple of teams and almost your role
becomes like a Sales Director kinda
wrong yeah yeah that can be tough to get
those levels and I think what we you
know what we ultimately did is it's
about investing ultimately invest and
not being scared to realize that you can
have to hire a number of people to be
able to get that level of
and unfortunately not all of them will
work out with the best intentions yet so
we did a couple of Academy so we had
like four people at once and then
incense to get some some critical mass
going get some momentum ultimately which
was about
let's pray the word see I think hiring
in groups of people at certain stages
help will help to help you to grow
cigarettes that momentum for the
business and and you know and pushes
pushes the business forward really so
how have you how have you got better
that's clearly the real challenge
obviously putting a lot of your money
and to do that's really willing to do
that so let's be realistic then so that
year to two year for get into this whole
fifteen head mark I mean was you pretty
much reinvesting majority of the profits
and enough to live on
it's still that now we're investing when
I grow grow the business and reinvest in
in Asuncion this latter timid in the
right knee business but it's people to
assume you know that you know you're
taking all the money in pay you know you
wanna I want to grow the business so the
most important seeing that and yeah I've
see ya every once live a comfortable
life and then you die and pay themselves
reasonably well but it's it's always
been the case that we want to be
invested in growing the people and so
we've done this year as well yeah I've
continually if that makes sense
okay so in the focus some of those sort
of the key learnings during that period
that mate 250 whatever like this or
barely stages but so you mentioned there
in terms of if you can build a bit
momentum from hiring more people at once
reinvest their money having that happens
and you need to buy then create your I
guess your framework and what your
business is about that make sense in
terms of marketing terms the way that
you sell ya terms you come it has a
price lyrics and your processes it looks
on the phone and it's being two
candidates clients different about you
processes so you need to I'd say that's
the difference four or five people you
can just kind of roll a long day today
yeah but you're pretty stagnate if you
don't have those in place if than many
sensitive you know what your business
about what purchases is about
mm so that's what we started what was
some of the biggest challenges during
that period then do you think for me I
was kind of back in that sort of
building manager role so again it's just
managing all the different people also
look into get to grow people to become
leaders as well yeah so it's not a
balancing your time yeah it's probably
the key thing from cuz and I'm assuming
and what you send there you like in
order for the business to grow you need
to ensure that you're spending time on
the business rather than the day-to-day
yeah in the trenches that balance is
probably the hardest thing for the owner
of the business just to make sure you're
officially at that stages lot of
business there I worked in and it was
like it should like it's just so easy
for me to grab you all the time and
exactly advice yes I can imagine slow a
bit shorter it's like especially that's
time you've got the million ideas where
the business great some some Momentum's
yes yeah so you start to think about
things like marketing and branding and
what happy you are starting to think
about okay what other markets can we go
into what are the sort of types of roles
can we recruit for how can we grow teams
yeah you've got a very different thought
process you've got a lot going on your
mind at once and also trying to build
traffic how was that how was that
process of you being in that position
where you as that billing them I just
sort of roll what so if I'm listening
right now and I'm in that sort of role
or I'm that's my environment right now
but I want to get to the point where I
may still have to be involved day to day
but I'm not as big a drug pillar to post
I'm I'm able to sort of ensure I have
enough time focusing on the business on
that's going in the right direction
what's the sort of process of going from
where you are really scattered doing all
different things to being able to focus
on the business what was that what does
that process look like what do people
need to start implementing and actually
I think one of the key things that we
did is bring in some support you at that
more senior level every day okay so we
hired a Sales Director yeah Liam is a
brilliant jobs beansprouts Betsy enough
three years now so ran that sort of time
I laugh yes yeah somebody coming in at a
senior level whether that be somebody
can grow internally the time we didn't
happen here with the right level of
experience so we bought something
externally
but somebody that can help to deal with
that the day to day and help to develop
and focus on the sales side the business
yeah so it gives you a bit more freedom
and headspace to look at the parts the
organization you can grow the overall
business if that makes sense
and I'm assuming that now when you're
talking about and the processes new
types of things for that to be an
effective hiring for you to maximize
that investment you must have made the
time to block right so if if someone
comes in and they do my job what is my
job look like what do I need them to be
doing and these I mean I'm sure that
must have had people need to think about
that absolutely what you know what and
also what you happy to give away
something yeah that could kind of
control thing and it's your babies and a
lot of people do struggle with that as
well the thing so how did you deal with
that because that can be difficult
especially that sort of stage right
because because again a lot I'm assuming
again crimine from wrong but I'm
assuming by that point I love the
business came from the founder brand
which is you as Tim like a lot
legislation's may be part of you or from
you Juneau means yeah exactly at that
time it was love relationships I'd
bought on yeah one that sort of party on
to other people exactly that
relationship I think it's it's um it's a
difficult one I think will depend on the
person's persona like as a characters as
to how willing they are to let go mmm
yes it is a process it's about trust
ultimately and and what have you know
we've got great directors and managers
right in the business right now but yeah
I guess it's it's a realization that
ultimately one human being on their own
there's a limit to what you can actually
achieve yeah yeah so you can get other
people to I think was it Steve Jobs it
says you know smart people tell me what
to do yeah that makes sense it's the
kind of realizing that actually you know
you can hive other people and bring the
other people into your business they're
actually pretty bet in your aspects of
the wrong yeah and give them freedom to
do that but it's not easy no it's it's
definitely a psychological battle
especially except right is that
crosspieces yeah of course because like
how like did you I don't know did you do
anything to sort of really get these
people to get brought in or help speed
up your trust I'm thinking I don't know
that this sort of stage was you talking
about look guys this is the journey
we're going on this
we're going there's opportunities to own
part of the business other yeah it's
about trust in both sides really because
for people to be bought into your
business that you need to trust that you
can flourish in as well so so you need
that from from both perspective so it's
an internal thing whether you're willing
to give then you know I have been in
terms of wanting to other people to you
know to exert and to trust them to do
that yeah and yeah we within our
business we've got a share scheme as
well our option scheme so most in the
company put that in a couple of couple
years after we started system a always
wanted to do it didn't have it in in the
femoris it with previously so I thought
I wanted an environment where everyone
felt some ownership how does actually
work then like is it a share scheme
where I've done arm like if you sell the
business they get X or like how each
dividends as well sometimes the era this
is near my scheme so it's done on the
company being sold at some point and
essentially you you can win more share
options every year depending on your
performance how much you bill yes your
team's performance and managers a direct
to the whole company performance and
also support staff the whole company
performance to every single person the
company you don't have to be like a
director and okay and how do you think
that's impacted people's commitment and
being he had been really brought into
the projects his journey has it you know
it's a company that's got a long-term
future that we're all working towards
yeah miss how things been it's been
really valuable for my perspective mmm
and from the feedback I've got as well
from from the team yeah you've got good
longevity of the people that have been
good you know and successful yeah I'm
staying in the company you know just
that's great just what we're talking
about that how important is it for you
then to communicate where the hell this
ship is going you know I mean that must
be Keith yeah and I think you know as
far as to be open and share where the
business is going so we have catch ups
at least once a quarter even sort of
share yeah I'm not just myself but all
the managers now she ever in the company
shares shares their their goals and mmm
we're where we're going as a company
where the managers won't take their
teams or the individuals won't take
their themselves as well and we also
look at not just the business but also
look into people's personal goals as
well yeah so you have you were typically
been open around that
yeah absolutely and I think you develop
up see over time and and
when you get to I think it's another
transition actually once you get to a
certain point not sure and Thalia went
when that was now but perhaps when you
get to that like 810 heads and grow
again yeah it's just realizing that the
the ultimate power as I said it's not
with you as the founder was with the
people people in the business and making
sure that they're in the best place they
can be to upgrade the business yeah
that's that's the key thing okay so to
run that off then and then we can sort
go into sort of more recent years yeah
so now you mentioned there let you talk
about figures for a sec what where where
was your Billings wise and and sort of
net feeling revenue wise sort of year
for how did that million mother in terms
of NFI million give or take not bad yeah
yeah so we'd kind of the two hundred
four hundred seven hundred million yeah
then we kind of plateaued actually for
one year really and I think that was
that when I start to have that
realization around destruction of
processes you get that next level and
hiring sales director et cetera so we
could we could take the next kick on
again if that makes sense okay and that
trust issue and let go okay so surround
the sort of year for might then hit the
million pound mark and NFI net for you
income and then what so then that sort
of period did you did you just say that
so you sort of plateaued and then push
on after that so then we plateau fear
then we did up to 1.5 so it's got a big
growth in one year when really what was
that what year six been last year right
yeah
and then what's your financial year is
it have you just you just finished it so
we did just under two million last year
really before January to December that's
amazing let's talk about those because
that's that's great growth right so
let's sort of unpack that and before we
finish then so clearly you've been
someone that sort of had the humility to
be like right okay so this is where out
what what can I are than I either spend
more time on the spend less time on so
we can push a business forward and
especially yeah so I guess but just
quickly just because again it always
comes up so at the year for my tea
around that sort of circa 50 head mark
now you're at you said just under 30
right yeah so it's really six and look
at our yeah yeah so let's just talk
about that for a second so from that
sort of you
to where you are now again what would
you think sort of impacted or had a yeah
enable you to do that some of the key
things again that is a difficult period
that a lot again I'm at fifteen heads
right now getting to sort of thirty
heads in it and growing the net fee
income and growing the the profits of
the business that may just seem like
impossible I'm always I'm always at that
Plateau what are some of the things that
sort of you've lunch or in that process
that have impact that do you think yeah
there's a couple of key things is
looking for leaders within your business
and obviously ya lookin to grow people
to become leaders is key there's team
leaders billion manager kind of roles
yeah and and help me to get this level
that that's that that's actually crucial
how to cultivate that how do you know I
mean yeah I mean actually some people to
lead others if make sense yeah manage
it's also making people obviously aware
as those that we discussed earlier they
can achieve a lot more if there's other
people and also the opportunity for
people to really enhance their careers
and you know to develop themselves okay
you know develop others is a key
challenge by the hardest thing in life
is is managing people there be a kids
yeah your family your friends or you
know in a business context and it's a
big challenge so making you know
encouraging people in our business to
give it a go yeah and obviously looking
people when we bring them in that would
want to okay but it's not you know it's
not for everyone it's not the B Mendel
but certainly to get that next level
from that sort of fifteen which is
you've got you know you have to have
that level I guess just to sort of run
that off I guess a part of that involves
that you effectively being able to
attract staff to your business yeah
that's a real challenge right it's a
real challenge in like how what what's
that been like for you as a business I'm
sure it's been become bit easier but
again that's the challenge for those
people listening that maybe on that sort
of ten fifteen mark even earlier online
how the [ __ ] I'm gonna get people for
the door is that very difficult you know
came through the doors hardest to think
once you know it seemed tell very story
and where you're going so yeah you know
it's about and then obviously managing
the process of meeting people et cetera
so after a while I think probably once
you get to about ten fifteen you'd
probably get a bit of a understanding of
what kind of you person looks like
so we also using being trying to be more
objective of the people you're hiring as
well I'm not just doing on gut so yeah
like psychometric profiling yeah we do
two different ones that we've done your
employees yeah everyone yeah smart
because that's come up a couple of times
and that's become not really impactful
and people who say whew it's real and
how its cost effective is that is that
affordable for us yeah yeah so anything
there's a couple of difference we do but
yeah it's like 1500 quid a pop so
another because it's nothing really how
when when would you do that would you do
that a lot after and after the first
stage but obviously not gonna just do
that on everyone I so I guess if we like
somebody really and how does that help
you make a better decision is it the
instead of just you'd go and run you
know what is a [ __ ] great guy or
great gal you can then have some backups
and stuff to back up back it up and some
stuff to challenge you as well okay yeah
this is what they like as a person also
to understand whether they're the
character would fit into the culture of
the business if it wouldn't I see yeah
it's around that is it's really
important to do hmm
understand the way that they sell and
what sort of salesperson I was really
important as well okay wrongly looking
too high so it's good to get some
science behind yeah four shillings
especially when you're yeah where that
stage degrades me like we're head people
are hard people normally in life right
yeah so you can get a bit both it's
gonna always help
what when do you think when do you think
is a real good time to really get
practical and more cuz I'm assuming the
10 mark 15 mark
I feel like got instinct insuring that
is this person gonna fit in Bubba Bligh
is probably a bit more important than
make is yeah so what is it like what
when you're break-in
when you can't no longer like completely
can what what I'm trying to say so like
when you get to a certain point that you
can't hire loads of Tim's do you know
I'm in yeah I think so yeah you know any
kind of rush things then because you're
trying to do so many jobs at once yeah
that's where needs plateau because yeah
yeah you know you're hiring people you
rushing the process you don't want to
grow etc but also you trying to balance
hundred things yes so yeah once you have
that realization I think that it's about
again for your hiring if you been this
minute we got a process in place and you
have anyone dedicated to getting trying
to get people through the door
we didn't up until about
six months ago oh [ __ ] really yeah so
how was you approach that then was you
just us have the mentality yeah it's me
that was primarily doing that so I was
always hiring and just learned yeah yeah
besides indirect and getting the guys to
refer people to us using rector X etc so
yeah would you again think again that
that's definitely something that
probably people are thinking about would
thinking gee that you feel like I should
have got someone dedicated to doing this
before six months ago or yeah well I
guess we've what we've done is it's kind
of a needs must up to up to that point
so I was doing some Rebecca yeah
mentioned earlier was doing some of our
internal creating when she was working
part time so I'm sharing it around but
what we realized is as I said it's kind
of a full-time focus yeah if you
actually get yeah get some be doing it
every day for one hour two hours yeah
it's amazing how much more effective
someone dipping in a nap
sorry hide Rebecca Cooper about six
months ago somebody's been doing
brilliant the people we've had already
been have been great so so the final
pinpoint on hi ring what a sort of them
you're sort of I know you mentioned
there you're getting some more science
behind your hiring stuff like that there
any sort of them non-negotiables for you
now through the sort of learning
experience over the last say years when
you when you hire people what they're
sorta non-negotiables for you is a
business important because people have
positive mindset really yeah that's
literally the most important thing
people how that wants it to grow and
happy to develop themselves and be
better
how did you find that interview just the
way they come across the sort of the
language the way they answer questions
yeah talk through some examples and
scenarios of what they've done the past
that sort of thing yeah
so that's that's the most important
thing for us people out there proactive
and positive really yeah that's right
now I think I think yeah I think that in
in recruitment if you're not positive
then there's so much negativity that can
happen that you can do that's the most
people they're naturally or or made made
themselves yeah but you can do it's
really important for us yeah okay cool
so I mean the the the the figures that
you showed advise that that's some great
growth right so I guess
let's unpack that bit so we've spoken
about the hiring strategy and your loans
through that and how you've got better
at that so has has you been able to sort
of I'm the Shipman because you've got
more people around you and cultivating
leaders in your business what is that
what do you think that's enabled you to
do in terms of focus on the business or
be able to give enough energy to that's
enabled you to sort of ensure this
businesses become more profitable do you
think any sort of key things run that
yeah absolutely I think one the key
things now that we've got in the
business is suddenly focus on on the
sales side the business okay and some of
the folks on the operations in terms of
everyday in temp says yeah managing
those processes yes
so Operations Director Rebecca and Liam
on the sales side so just quickly my
roles completely change now so what just
just so I think it's pretty clear what
Rebecca does right so they sell Liam
what so what's his role so he manages
the sales teams essentially and that's
their housing your business now so
you've done their BD so you've got the
180 model we've got we've got a mixture
actually okay what so it were quite
flexible from our perspective in terms
of we've got a BD person in each team or
hiring for them at the moment
then we've got some market specialists
360 and a couple of people that kind of
born the journey in terms of do some BD
but more yes it's a bit of a bit of a
hybrid blend but that's a few reasons to
get the best out of people some people
in a sense family yeah paid to their
strengths which is very important to do
but also from b-being perspective we've
realized if we ever have been purpose
business and if we have ups and downs
that you get with perlier it's quite
often because the jobs and the BDC yeah
so having someone always dedicated to
that yeah so that's been quite a big
impact on yeah it's the next level of
evolution first step is really to get
that next level you've got
acylium you've got someone dedicated to
helping the the guys and girls who have
focused on BD sales wind and clients
jobs focus on helping them maximize
their efforts in the context of it yeah
and manage that the managers the team
leaders it's a 40 metres yeah so is that
I'm assuming someone who used today yeah
as part of my role so and how long has
he been there not for saram so then my
role changed into kind of managing him
but also keep an eye on that client
development side of things but then also
look at more the ops side mmm the
marketing and the office and the
business and name backwards a certain
point where I realized again I spread
myself too thin mmm and then you know
it's effective actually yeah when you're
doing that so I wanted to hire somebody
that could help us develop have the best
process in terms of the structure of the
business look at how we can hire more
great people for our business you're the
most important thing yeah and also you
know manage the marketing aspects as
well which is you know yourself your
marketing is it's actually huge yeah
okay so so that is that what you do now
then what is that okay so now I manage
those two guys and then my focus is
looking at ways we can track people to
our business more holistically if that
makes sense yeah and then also looking
at business development for us again how
you can already business from a sales
perspective as well so kind of more more
overarching if that makes sense or no
still rather than the sort day-to-day
you know you can maximize that call it's
more of like strictly yeah well it's
what markets can we go into what
countries can we look at that can enable
us to sort of yeah so I've got time to
kind of to think what you think you know
at times you don't get more time to
think well that's a good thing I don't
know we'll find out but I'm sure and
then how involved you get light in terms
of like driving culture in your business
now like I'm assuming like I'm assuming
you're very in the business you are
sighs now like are you still very
accessible and you know I mean yeah
obviously sit with everyone in the
office and sort of go around the sales
floor and just catch up with people
briefly yeah throughout the day posted
on trend on people's toes at the same
time it's good to find out and get
barometer of how people are getting on
so yeah really important to do that and
to get to catch up but everyone to make
sure everyone's doing well but yeah the
most important thing is you know we get
a lot of feedback from the people as
well and the consultants and within the
business yeah and everyone on the
employees in terms of what we can
improve yeah so look at those aspects
and go okay
what can we do holistically as a hope is
in the air and I little bit better every
day so that's key and may get feedback
from people make sure everyone's happy
you know you want you want people come
into work with a smile on that face yeah
you know recording as we discussed there
Monday Monday yeah you know that you
know that those feelings that you know
the opposite of what ultimate you'd want
in a company in that that's key to us so
yeah it's about providing that platform
where people are going to enjoy what
they do and they we're gonna you know
hopefully get the best out of them okay
so before before we finish then I mean
that that all seems really positive and
I love the way sort of it seems like you
just become more and more comfortable
with loading off some of the
responsibilities that you've challenged
for a lot of people now it has been for
me I was gonna say what's been the
biggest challenges during the last sort
of 2-3 years for you then personally
because yeah how is it as it has there
been any challenges on other neither
personal
maximizing my time across all aspects of
my life I think is the mini challenge
really so you know I think sometimes you
get to a point we do little bits in
every area but you're not that effective
in yeah yeah yeah
so having the realization that yeah
there's other people that pretty better
at certain aspects of whatever it might
be the new so giving them the freedom to
do that yeah and then they can become
more creative with different ideas they
can some time out to breathe and think
of different ideas mm-hmm it's really
important as well so what do you do for
that like how do you do that do you let
your book out time or yeah sometimes
book out time or at least if you don't
have constant day-to-day things to think
about and it gives you that they give
you - yeah and you start to think and
research things and go okay yeah that
sort of thing so any any things that any
sort of real practical advice that I
don't know you've implemented over the
last couple years in terms of managing
time and maximizing your time that you
want a structured making sure that you
have structure in the business we've got
some advice in this as well where you
know you know constantly having meetings
people out batteries that come into your
head if they make sense yes it's not
that productive thing to do yeah
organizing yourself so thanks Rebecca
we've got like you know a good way that
we open ourselves on planner and what
have you and you've got a bit more
structure in terms of when you're
communicating
yeah it's you see you just be grabs for
light just naturally what I do so just
yeah making sure that you're a bit more
process driven in terms of that side
everything's really important yeah so
future then what's going on so 2020 new
decade this has got to be the year the
vision than it was the vision that like
me it was so this year we want to grow
double the size that the sales team in
terms the consultants and the BD yeah to
people of people recruiting its create
we've got some targets from the guys to
set up a business in America for us so
people working towards that so another
fiscal officer well the actual
opportunity I mean it's really it's
coming up a lot now isn't it I mean it
yeah lot of businesses moving to America
and stuff like that water is massive
especially in our market as well because
the medical I think it's 10 out of the
top 20 pay jobs in America and medical
related how well because of insurance
are you sort of trying to execute one UK
and then with unrolls from the UK yeah
in America and then if it goes well get
some traction potentially move open
again in our market it's not huge
exposure over there in terms of
specialist companies lots of businesses
number of really good ones over there
but generally speaking there's known
really working the way we work in terms
of our processes we know about that from
the conversation I've had that seems a
and sort of competitive advance from day
one that typically a recruiter in
America will cover like if I were for
you if I recruit for you then I'll
recruit about all your roles rather than
I don't know I just do that so how have
you have you identified a lot of
potential estate to go after anything
like that or is it quiet it's still
fairly early we're focusing on the East
Coast off with time different time to
finish it and we're working with clients
a lot of our nothing but our market a
lot of companies our American
starting lots of work in Europe so how
you can leverage potentially something
moving back up the food chain so to
speak and speaking to people UPS in the
US and helping them to build out the
teams as well yeah is what we're doing
so yeah so early days
mm-hmm but yeah that's a bit excited
about America growing actual headcount
of the business yep for this year
creating more managers as well and I
often people to move up our food chain
and create promotions for people in the
business really critical we've got a
management training program at the
moment you set up a Future Leaders
program as well call the people that
want to be leaders in the future that's
crucial for this year - everyone's
progression than they make exactly and
that's you know you've got to be able to
give people the platform to progressing
yeah deserve it that's really crucial of
it that we do that obviously you've been
in recruitment for a while what what
what what do you see from your
perspective in your experience that's
sort of on the horizon for a criminal
what do you sort of expect over the next
sort of decade or next year or so that
yeah it's gonna be huge innovation both
in our market in terms of med tech but
also I'm recruitment as well I think
yeah the market is obviously changing as
well it's about adding real value think
to your clients and candidates yeah real
real value for them and helping to grow
their businesses not just putting a bomb
on the seat so yeah what else can you do
what services can you offer to your
clients to help them so to really to
excel as a business and to grow their
business yeah what things do you think
sort of fall into that category making
sure they've got their you know they
sort of company people who want to work
for helping with that
yeah they employ a brand oh yeah and
then their media work and what have you
advise him on that make sure that I'm
boarding is on point yeah really digging
into that sort of detail consulting with
them ultimately mm-hmm and offering a
consultative solutions helping their
businesses grow um
not just for live a conceive that makes
sense yeah she's been more of an actual
partner yeah real absolutely that's why
I will definitely happen adding real
valley yeah rather than just anything
transactional because that can be done
by some companies directly or through
through through tech if that makes sense
yeah where's the real consulting piece
and adding human value yeah is what will
be enhanced and continue to grow things
yeah just a quick comment before we
finish I think I think I'm always
curious about this and I think that's
important to talk about it how what's
the journey been with you like your your
your personal life in your relationships
like management and Grannis business
obviously like how's that been there's
that being quite easy to keep on top
I'm sure there's been Chinese along the
way it's not nothing nothing is easy if
that makes sense so yeah of course
they're um you know that there's a lot
more a lot more going on your brain
ultimately yeah if you own your own
business then they would other people
because you thinking about you know you
have to think about things a lot more
you get a lot more different thought
process coming through you know you're
managing yourself you're so responsible
for loads of other people yeah your
family life as well yeah and going on
yeah a lot going on basically so trying
to make sure you've got some sort of
balance and release and of course you
have the ups and downs within that so
one of the key things we do is try and
share our goals of business the five
pillars project is we share different
goals with each other yeah so happen
tonight personal guard doesn't have to
be on a build this this year it's no the
business goes finance and money and what
happy to make sure people got some goals
around that as well your mind so mind
set goals nice health as well and also
relationships yeah yeah so taking the
time out making sure you you reconnect
with people and you you encourage people
to openly share those yeah so for a
couple years I just got the idea from
chocolate Andrew Sileo sort of yeah
program and we added one more on there
we've doing that for a long time so
everyone everyone shares those every
quarter with each other that's wicked
and so cheer each other to achieve them
right it's very hard to keep up five in
I think it also helps you know you know
you're very close personal relationship
can help in terms if you know if you've
got a partner might be making sure that
they're there behind you which my life
is obsolete been and that helps to keep
me kind of grounded and motivated mmm in
the days that go up and down and then
obviously responsibilities of the team
as well I mean yeah sure that you're on
point for them mmm-hmm but you
definitely I think needs some releases
sometimes whether that be for some
people it's exercise isn't it well you
you've got a a personal going here which
is yeah and so when's that April you
raising money for that right yeah raise
money for mine don't you talk about
support so you know you've never like
what's like the most you've rounded
perhaps about four years ago four years
ago and that's it that's it yeah I
wanted to do it again - so challenge my
brain where you don't want to do
anything - sometimes do things that you
won't necessarily want to be sure will
help you well so I think you've been on
a great journey mate I think it's great
sort of I think what's clear is you've
all cleared someone that's always had
sort of humility and that seemed like
they haven't sort of let your ego
getting away and in any way shape or
form so the last question I always ask
everyone on the show is if you could
communicate to every single recruits
recruitment business owner out there and
they'd take on your advice that
implement it tomorrow could be a phrase
a sentence
anything what what comes to mind if
they'd listen to Tim so don't try and do
everything on your own look at the
people for help and advice and guidance
really mm-hmm
you know alone ultimately you're not
alone yeah I like that okay so it's been
a pleasure mate thank you thank you